this light Shaw is usually restricted to
the Arctic but has been visible over
Lake Alberta and Canada and as far south
as the U.S state of New Mexico
the rare phenomenon is caused by solar
wind particles smashing into the Earth's
atmosphere and turning energy into light
and they're said to be more displays
over the next two years
that's because the sun is reaching the
most active part of its 11 year cycle
the storm has thrown Vivid colors across
the sky in Europe including this light
show in Finland
scientists observing the flares in
Sweden say it is not dangerous although
the geomagnetic activity has the
strength to knock out power grids
people now cannot make I cannot imagine
the life without GPS satellite TV mobile
phone and so on to have all this we need
to know space Quest when we have strong
captivity
activity all this stuff can be destroyed
due to space Quest there have been no
reports of power cut so far for now in
the northern hemisphere there's all and
wonder for people looking up
foreign